NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD EVER HEAR
OUR ALLIES SAY SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
OVER THE PAST YEAR I'VE DIRECTED
FEDERAL AGENCIES TO PROMOTE
ACCESS TO VOTING.
LED BY THE VICE PRESIDENT.
WE'VE APPOINTED TOP CIVIL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES TO HELP THE U.S.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, WHICH HAS
DOUBLED ITS VOTING RIGHTS
ENFORCEMENT STAFF.
TODAY WE CALL ON CONGRESS TO GET
DONE WHAT HISTORY WILL JUDGE --
PASS THE FREEDOM TO VOTE ACT.
PASS IT NOW!
WHICH WOULD PREVENT VOTER
SUPPRESSION.
SO HERE IN GEORGIA, THERE'S FULL
ACCESS TO VOTING BY MAIL.
THERE ARE ENOUGH DROP BOXES
DURING ENOUGH HOURS SO YOU CAN
BRING FOOD AND WATER AS WELL TO
PEOPLE WAITING IN LINE.
THE FREEDOM TO VOTE ACT TAKES ON
ELECTION SUBVERSION TO PROTECT
NONPARTISAN ELECTORS, OFFICIALS
WHO DURING THEIR JOB FROM
INTIMIDATION AND INTERFERENCE.
IT WOULD GET DARK MONEY OUT OF
POLITICS, CREATE FAIR DISTRICT
MAPS AND ENDING PARTISAN
GERRYMANDERING.
LOOK, IT'S ALSO TIME TO PASS THE
JOHN LEWIS VOTING RIGHTS
ADVANCEMENT ACT.
I HAVE BEEN HAVING THESE QUIET
CONVERSATIONS WITH MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS FOR THE LAST TWO
MONTHS.
I'M TIRED OF BEING QUIET!
FOLKS, IT WILL RESTORE THE
STRENGTH OF THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACT OF '65, THE ONE PRESIDENT
JOHNSON SIGNED AFTER JOHN LEWIS
WAS BEATEN, NEARLY KILLED ON
BLOODY SUNDAY.
ONLY TO HAVE THE SUPREME COURT
WEAKEN IT MULTIPLE TIMES OVER
THE PAST DECADE.
RESTORING THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT
WOULD MEAN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT CAN STOP
DISCRIMINATORY LAWS BEFORE THEY
GO INTO EFFECT.
BEFORE THEY GO INTO EFFECT.
THE VICE PRESIDENT AND I HAVE
SUPPORTED VOTING RIGHTS BILLS
SINCE DAY ONE OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION, BUT EACH AND
EVERY TIME SENATE REPUBLICANS
HAVE BLOCKED THE WAY.
REPUBLICANS OPPOSE EVEN DEBATING
THE ISSUE.
YOU HEAR ME?
I HAVE BEEN AROUND THE SENATE A
LONG TIME.
I WAS VICE PRESIDENT FOR EIGHT
YEARS.
I'VE NEVER SEEN A CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE NOT ONE SINGLE REPUBLICAN
HAS A VOICE THAT'S READY TO
SPEAK FOR JUSTICE NOW.
WHEN I WAS A SENATOR, INCLUDING
WHEN I HEADED UP THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, I HELPED REAUTHORIZE
THE VOTING ACT THREE TIMES.
WE HELD HEARINGS, DEBATED, WE
VOTED.
WAS ABLE TO EXTEND THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT FOR 25 YEARS.
IN 2006, THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT
PASSED 300-33 IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES AND 98-0 IN THE
SENATE.
WITH VOTES FROM 16 CURRENT
SITTING REPUBLICANS IN THIS
UNITED STATES SENATE.
16 OF THEM VOTED TO EXTEND IT.
LAST YEAR I WAS CHAIRMAN, SOME
OF MY FRIENDS SITTING DOWN HERE
WILL TELL YOU, STROM THURMOND
VOTED TO EXTEND THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT.
STROM THURMOND.
YOU CAN SAY THAT AGAIN, WOW.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA HOW DAMN --
DARN HARD I WORKED ON THAT ONE.
BUT FOLKS, THEN IT WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW THE LAST TIME BY
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH.
YOU KNOW, WHEN WE GET VOTING
RIGHTS EXTENDED IN 1980, AS I
SAID, EVEN THURMOND SUPPORTED
IT.
THINK ABOUT THAT -- THE MAN WHO
LED ONE OF THE LONGEST
FILIBUSTERS IN HISTORY IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE, 1957
AGAINST THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
THE MAN WHO LED AND SIDED WITH
OLD SOUTHERN BULLS IN THE UNITED
STATES SENATE TO PERPETUATE
SEGREGATION IN THIS NATION, EVEN
STROM THURMOND CAME TO SUPPORT
VOTING RIGHTS.
BUT REPUBLICANS TODAY CAN'T AND
WON'T.
NOT A SINGLE REPUBLICAN HAS
DISPLAYED THE COURAGE TO STAND
UP TO A DEFEATED PRESIDENT TO
PROTECT AMERICA'S RIGHT TO VOTE.
NOT ONE.
NOT WHERE ONE.
WE HAVE 50/50 IN THE UNITED
STATES SENATE.
THAT MEANS WE HAVE 51
PRESIDENTS.
YOU ALL THINK I'M KIDDING.
I HAVE BEEN PRETTY GOOD AT
WORKING WITH SENATORS MY CAREER,
BUT MAN, WHEN YOU GOT 51
PRESIDENTS, IT GETS HARDER.
ANY ONE CAN CHANGE THE OUTCOME.
SADLY, THE UNITED STATES SENATE
DESIGNED TO BE THE WORLD'S
GREATEST DELIBERATIVE BODY, HAS
BEEN RENDERED A SHELL OF ITS
FORMER SELF.
GIVES ME NO SATISFACTION IN
SAYING THAT, AS AN
INSTITUTIONALIST, AS A MAN WHO
WAS HONORED TO SERVE IN THE
SENATE.
BUT AS AN INSTITUTIONALIST, I
BELIEVE THE THREAT TO DEMOCRACY
IS SO GREY THAT WE MUST FIND A
WAY TO PASS THESE VOTING RIGHTS
BILLS.
DEBATE THEM, VOTE, LET THE
MAJORITY PREVAIL.
AND AT THAT VERY MINUTE IT WAS
BLOCKED, WE HAD NO OPTION BUT TO
CHANGE THE SENATE RULES,
INCLUDING GETTING RID OF THE
FILIBUSTER FOR THIS.
YOU KNOW, LAST YEAR, IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN, THE FILIBUSTER WAS
USED 154 TIMES.
THE FILIBUSTER HAS BEEN USED TO
GENERATE COMPROMISE IN THE PAST,
PROMOTE OF BIPARTISAN, BUT IT'S
ALSO USED TO OBSTRUCT, INCLUDING
ESPECIALLY TO OBSTRUCT CIVIL
RIGHTS AND VOTING RIGHTS.
AND WHEN IT WAS USED, SENATORS
USED TO TRADITIONALLY HAVE TO
STAND AND SPEAK AT THEIR DESK
FOR HOWEVER LONG IT TOOK.
SOMETIMES FOR HOURS.
WHENEVER THEY SAT DOWN, IF
NOBODY IMMEDIATELY STOOD UP,
ANYONE COULD CALL FOR A VOTE, TO
HAVE DEBATE ENDED.
BUT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN TODAY.
SENATORS NO LONGER EVEN HAVE TO
SPEAK ONE WORD.
FILIBUSTER'S NOT USED BY
REPUBLICANS TO BRING THE SENATE
TOGETHER, BUT TO PULL IT FURTHER
APART.
FILIBUSTER'S BEEN WEAPONIZED AND
ABUSED WHILE THE STATE LEG
E
LEGISLATOR'S VAULT ON VOTES
RIGHTS IS SIMPLE, ALL YOU NEED
IN YOUR HOUSE IS A MAJORITY.
IN THE UNITED STATES SENATE IT
TAKES A SUPER MAJORITY.
60 VOTES EVEN TO GET A VOTE.
STATE LEGISLATURES CAN PASS
ANTI-VOTING RIGHTS LAWS WITH
SIMPLE MAJORITIES.
IF THEY CAN DO THAT, THE UNITED
STATES SENATE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
CHECK BY A SIMPLE MAJORITY.
TODAY I'M MAKING IT CLEAR -- TO
PROTECT OUR DEMOCRACY I SUPPORT
CHANGING THE SENATE RULES,
WHICHEVER WAY THEY NEED TO BE
CHANGED TO PREVENT A MINORITY OF
SENATES FROM BLOCKING ACTION ON
VOTING RIGHTS.
WHEN IT COMES TO PROTECTING
MAJORITY RULE IN AMERICA, THE
MAJORITY SHOULD RULE IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
I MAKE THIS ANNOUNCEMENT WITH
CAREFUL DELIBERATION,
RECOGNIZING THE FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT TO VOTE IS A RIGHT FROM
WHICH ALL OTHER RIGHTS FLOW.
AND I MAKE IT WITH AN APPEAL TO
MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES, TO
THOSE REPUBLICANS WHO BELIEVE IN
THE RULE OF LAW, RESTORE THE
BIPARTISAN TRADITION OF VOTING
RIGHTS.
PEOPLE WHO RESTORED IT -- WHO
ABIDED BY IT IN THE PAST WERE
RICHARD NIXON, GERALD FORD,
RONALD REAGAN, GEORGE H.W. BUSH,
GEORGE W. BUSH.
THEY ALL SUPPORTED THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT.
DON'T LET THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
M
MORPH INTO SOMETHING ELSE.
RESTORE THE SENATE TO THE WAY IT
WAS DESIGNED TO BE.
SENATE RULES WERE CHANGED TO --
THE DEBT CEILING SO WE WOULDN'T
RENEGE ON OUR DEBT FOR THE FIRST
TIME, CREATE AN ECONOMIC CRISIS.
THAT WAS DONE BY SIMPLE
MAJORITY.
SENATOR WARNOCK SAID A FEW WEEKS
AGO IN A POPULAR SPEECH, IF WE
CHANGE THE RULES TO REFPROTECT
THE -- WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
CHANGE THE RULES TO PROTECT THE
HEART AND SOUL OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
IN THE DAYS THAT FOLLOWED, JOHN
LEWIS AT THE DEATH, THERE WAS AN
OUTPOURING OF PRAISE ACROSS THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM.
BUT AS WE STAND HERE TODAY, IT
ISN'T ENOUGH TO PRAISE, WE MUST
TRANSLATE.
WE NEED TO FOLLOW JOHN LEWIS'
FOOTSTEPS.
WE NEED TO SUPPORT THE BILL IN
HIS NAME.
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO WE TALKED
ABOUT -- UP IN THE CONGRESS AND
THE WHITE HOUSE, THE EVENT
COMING UP SHORTLY TO CELEBRATE
DR. KING'S BIRTHDAY.
AND AMERICANS OF ALL STRIPES
WILL PRAISE HIM FOR THE CONTENT
OF HIS CHARACTER.
BUT AS DR. KING'S FAMILY SAID
BEFORE IT'S NOT NOW HAVE PRAISE
THEIR FATHER.
THEY EVEN SAID, ON THIS HOLIDAY,
DON'T CELEBRATE HIS BIRTHDAY
UNLESS YOU'RE WILLING TO SUPPORT
WHAT HE LIVED FOR AND WHAT HE
DIED FOR.
THE NEXT FEW DAYS, WHEN THESE
BILLS COME TO A VOTE, WILL MARK
A TURNING POINT IN THIS NATION'S
HISTORY.
WE WILL CHOOSE.
THE ISSUE, WILL WE CHOOSE
DEMOCRACY OVER AUTOCRACY, LIGHT
OVER SHADOWS, JUSTICE OVER
INJUSTICE?
I KNOW WHERE I STAND.
I WILL NOT YIELD.
I WILL NOT FLINCH.
I WILL DEFEND THE RIGHT TO VOTE
OUR DEMOCRACY AGAINST ALL
ENEMIES, FOREIGN AND, YES,
DOMESTIC.
THE QUESTION IS, WHERE WILL WILL
INSTITUTION OF THE UNITED STATES
SENATE STAND?
EVERY SENATOR -- DEMOCRAT,
REPUBLICAN, AND INDEPENDENT --
WILL HAVE TO DECLARE WHERE THEY
STAND.
NOT JUST FOR THE MOMENT BUT FOR
THE AGES.
WILL YOU STAND AGAINST VOTER
SUPPRESSION?
YES OR NO.
THAT'S THE QUESTION THEY'LL
ANSWER.
WILL YOU STAND AGAINST ELECT